it's a business opportunity you go door  to door we saw magazines we store like  America we party come with us  got anybody was gonna miss you not  really  okay good you're hired is she okay oh  yeah you gotta keep bringing prayers on  I've been trying to be Christian but I  can see the devil has a hold of the two  of you the devil has a hold of your  daughter where are you going make money  up here I make money on  I like a girl is fun party to get keys  get money or jumping to car jumping do  you have any dreams it's our future  proves it was ever a sphere you think  you're special  you don't mean that any  Wow  scared bang  you guys came in 53 million dollars  lower than the nearest competition Oh